hey 42 here in 333 bc
alexander the great led his army into
the phrygian capital
of gordium in modern-day turkey where
as the story goes he found an ancient
wagon
the yolk of the wagon was secured with a
nest of knots
so intricate it was impossible to see
how the rope was tied together
legend had it the wagon had belonged to
gordius the father of king midas
and according to an oracle whoever was
able to undo the massive knots
would become the ruler of all asia since
conquering the known world was quite
high up on alexander's to-do list
he immediately had a go at unravelling
the ropes but with no success
after muttering a few macedonian
expletives
the young king took a step back and
looked at the problem
from a different angle it occurred to
him that it didn't matter
how the knot was untied just that it was
broken
so he took out his sword and sliced a
knot in half
just the sort of thing you'd expect from
someone whose surname is
the great alexander would go on to prove
the oracle right by building an
empire that stretched across three
continents and covered around 2 million
square miles
whilst the gordian knot became a symbol
for
seemingly unsolvable problems that
require
a fresh insight to decode we have more
than a few gordian knots around
these days like how do we stop climate
change
what do we do if we run out of water
and how do we integrate the standard
model of particle physics with the
theory of general relativity
okay that last one probably isn't the
top of your mind whilst you're munching
on your breakfast cereal or swiping
right on tinder
but it keeps physicists awake at night
because
unless we answer this question we may
never
understand the nature of reality
the problem is this modern physics is
based on two major systems
that don't agree with each other the
theory of general relativity helps us
understand the really big stuff like
planets stars galaxies and kanye west's
ego
whilst quantum mechanics helps us
understand all the really small stuff
like
molecules atoms and the subatomic world
both these theories are extremely
successful which in scientific terms
means they consistently make
accurate predictions not that they drive
ferraris and have deepak
chopra on speed dial independently these
theories have revealed the nature of
space
and the basic structure of mata but
when we try to combine them things get
awkward
for the last 50 years scientists have
managed to ignore the cosmic elephant in
the room
but certain questions keep coming up
which have highlighted the conflict
between quantum mechanics
and general relativity at the center of
a black hole for example
extreme gravity means massive amounts of
matter are crushed to a minuscule size
and at the moment of the big bang the
whole universe erupted from a
microscopic
particle in both these examples the
insanely big
and the insanely small are present at
the same time
so we need a set of rules that explains
what happens in those scenarios
but neither general relativity nor
quantum mechanics alone
are able to do that this is the central
problem
of modern physics which is why
for more than 100 years scientists have
been searching
for an ultimate theory a master theory a
theory of everything that could explain
well everything this would be
the sword that slices through the
gordian knot
and there are currently a few different
candidates for a theory of everything
but more on that later first we need to
understand how we got ourselves in this
mess in the first place
and to do that we need to get our heads
around force
no not the time yoda uses to lift
women's skirts
we're talking about the four fundamental
forces of
nature gravity electromagnetism
the weak nuclear force and the strong
nuclear force
as anyone with half an hour's worth of
gum wrapper education could tell you
the force of gravity was discovered by
sir isaac newton
a scientific genius who also established
the laws of motion
and a whole new branch of mathematics
you know and love as calculus
or at least a modern version of it
though newton only shared the story much
later in life
the legend of how he came upon the law
of gravity
began in 1665 with him sitting in deep
fort in his garden
ordinarily he would have been attending
lectures at the university of cambridge
but the school was closed and the
students were sent home due to a
national outbreak of the bubonic plague
sound familiar newton preferred to rely
on observation
and testing over theory this was a guy
who when studying optics stuck a blunt
needle in his eye to see what happened
instead of trusting the textbooks of the
time like i said
the genius so when he saw an apple fall
from a tree in his garden
he forgot theory and came up with a
brand new perspective
on what had caused the apple to drop
gravity is such a basic part of our
lives
that it's hard to imagine a time when
our species had no real
clue how it worked but back when newton
first began developing his ideas
some theologians still believed planets
moved due to the beating of angels wings
and scientific theory was still largely
based on the work of ancient greek
philosophers
from thousands of years before it wasn't
even called science
yet what newton studied was known as
natural philosophy
at the time newton's professors were
still teaching aristotle's view of the
world
which was that some substances like
apples
had a quality called gravity which made
them full
whilst others like smoke had a quality
called levity
which made them rise newton realized
gravity is a force that pulls things
down to earth
but his law of universal gravitation
went further to say that gravity acts on
all objects including planets
newton was the first person to
understand why planets stayed in orbit
and how the force that kept the earth
circling the sun
was the same one that made apples fall
from trees
in modern scientific language newton
unified celestial
and terrestrial gravity instead of
two separate explanations for two
effects
both could now be explained by one
complete
theory a theory of everything would have
the same goal
but on steroids unification was also
behind the discovery of the second major
force
electromagnetism by the late 19th
century electricity and magnetism had
been known for millennia
magnets occur naturally in the form of
magnetite and
lodestone whilst electricity is all
around us
just think of lightning or electric eels
by the late 1800s a few studies have
been published showing a connection
between electricity and
magnetism but they were always
considered separate phenomena
it wasn't until james clark maxwell
published his list of differential
equations
imaginatively called maxwell's equations
that we understood electricity and
magnetism to be different
expressions of one electromagnetic force
the final two forces we would need to
include in a theory of everything
are the weak and strong nuclear forces
which were only discovered fairly
recently
the strong force was identified in 1973
and
there which was predicted in the 60s the
weak force was only confirmed in 1983
but before we dive into those forces a
quick word on subatomic particles
the ancient greeks believed the world
was composed of fundamental building
blocks of reality called
atoms a name which came from the greek
term atomos which means
indivisible these were thought to be
unbreakable pieces of matter
so small they couldn't be seen like
microscopic lego that connected in
different ways
to create the objects we see around us
like so many ancient greek predictions
this turned out to be amazingly close to
the truth
researchers in the 19th century proved
that common substances like
oxygen and carbon were made of smaller
units
which as a nod to the guys in togas they
called
atoms by the early 20th century though
it was clear atoms were made up of even
smaller components called protons
neutrons and electrons
and in 1913 the world was introduced to
the solar system model of the atom that
we know so well today
but as technology has evolved and our
ability to analyze the subatomic world
has improved
even smaller components of reality have
been discovered
in the 1930s physicists discovered the
muon
similar to an electron but about 200
times heavier
in the 50s conclusive evidence was found
for the existence of the neutrino
an invisible particle that moves through
mata like it doesn't matter
i did a whole video on those mysterious
little buggers recently
then in 1968 researchers at the stanford
linear accelerator center
found that protons and neutrons aren't
even
fundamental turns out they're made up of
even smaller particles called quarks
so far as we can tell quarks truly are
fundamental
and can't be further divided and they
may not even have
size at all as they're too small for us
to measure
even with our highest resolving
equipment
but then again we used to think that's
about atoms too
so you never know it may be that as
technology keeps improving we'll be able
to keep
zooming further and further into
subatomic particles
and who knows what we may find perhaps
at the heart of all reality there's a
tiny old lady making mata
out of pancake batter in a matter of
decades physicists have identified
hundreds of different subatomic
particles
with names like lepton tau and other
words you might hear at a star wars
convention
physicists needed some way to make sense
of it all and
so emerged the standard model of
particle physics
the standard model is considered by many
to be the most successful theory
ever devised and it provides a solid
framework for understanding and
predicting the behavior of particles
in the subatomic world naturally without
some kind of force
these particles will be moving around
chaotically
so physical forms including you and i
would shift and change
constantly i find it hard enough to keep
my [ __ ] together as it is
fortunately for us all there are at
least three forces maintaining order in
the quantum universe
we've already met the electromagnetic
force that amongst other things
keeps electrons obediently orbiting the
nuclei of atoms
the weak force is responsible for
particle decay which is when one
subatomic particle like a proton or an
electron
decides it would like to change into a
bunch of other subatomic particles
for no apparent reason without the weak
force we wouldn't have the nuclear
fusion reactions that power the sun
and produce the energy needed for life
on earth so
it's fairly important the strong force
binds quarks in clusters
that make up subatomic particles like
protons and neutrons
and also holds together the atomic
nucleus itself
if someone at a subatomic cocktail party
were to ask the strong force what it
does for a living
it would say something like i'm
responsible for the underlying stability
of
all matter then it would down a bottle
of tequila
and ride away on a unicorn made of fire
unlike gravity and the electromagnetic
force which can operate
across great distances the strong force
and the weak force only work over
incredibly short distances we're talking
just a couple of fentometers at the very
most
how big is a femtometer about the size
of a proton
so yeah pretty damn small perhaps
unsurprisingly
the strong force is the strongest of
forces
followed by the electromagnetic force
which is a hundred times weaker
and then the weak force which is one
hundred thousand times weaker
the strong force is six thousand
trillion trillion trillion times
stronger than gravity
which in the world of forces is a total
wimp gravity doesn't even show up at a
quantum level so it's not included in
the standard model of particle physics
and so we arrive back at our original
problem
the conflict between classical physics
which is based on gravity
and quantum physics which is based on
the other three forces
things first went awry in the late 1800s
when it was realized
newton's laws of motion and james clark
maxwell's laws of electromagnetism
contradicted each other particularly
when it came to light
according to newton you could catch up
to a beam of light if you ran fast
enough
according to maxwell you couldn't this
disagreement was eventually resolved by
albert einstein
whose theory of special relativity
proved that space and time
are relative not fixed as people had
always believed
quite a few physicists needed a stiff
drink after that one
unfortunately einstein's genius was
about to bite back
because the development of the special
theory of relativity
set up a new inconsistency this time
with newton's well-tested
universal theory of gravitation
einstein's work concluded that nothing
could travel faster than the speed of
light
but newton's calculations suggested
gravity operated across
vast distances of space instantly
clever clocks that he was uncle albert
fixed that issue too
using a new and improved notion of
gravity he detailed in his 1915 creation
the general theory of relativity this
hypothesis suggested space and time are
warped and
curved by matter and energy and these
changes to the space-time landscape are
responsible
for what we experience as gravity
which isn't actually a force at all but
once again
in solving one problem einstein had only
highlighted another
in the early 20th century physicists
including einstein himself
began developing the field of quantum
mechanics and it soon became clear that
gravity
and the theory of general relativity
didn't apply at the quantum level
at the same time electromagnetism which
was the only other force known at the
time
couldn't explain the many mysteries of
the cosmos on its own
einstein became obsessed with the
problem and spent the next 30 years
searching for what he called
a unified field theory a framework that
could explain all the physics from the
macro
to the micro but as you've probably
worked out by now
einstein never succeeded and nor has
anyone else
today there are a few candidates for a
theory of everything that might
unify the free forces of quantum physics
with the gravitational force of
classical physics
but for now they're just that theories
there's been little or no evidence of
these working
in experiments so we definitely can't
declare any of them to be true
perhaps the most promising pretender to
the crown is string
theory this mathematical model proposes
all the different subatomic particles
known to science
are not particles at all but rather
hypothetical strings that vibrate in
different ways
according to this theory the vibration
of a string amongst other things
determines whether it will show up as a
proton or a quark
or something else entirely for this
model to work the universe needs to have
many more dimensions than the three or
possibly four if you want to get all
fancy and include time
that we're familiar with most likely 10
whilst the strings themselves
need to be one dimensional so they only
have length
no width or height don't try to imagine
it
seriously your brain will explode
just like rocky movies there seemed to
be a never-ending stream of new string
theories so in the late 20th century
scientists gathered the five string
theories that
existed at the time under a more general
framework
called m theory which presumably just to
one up the other string theories
requires 11 dimensions weirdly nobody
really knows what the m
in m theory stands for the best guess is
membrane but apparently it might also be
master
matrix mother magic or monster
clearly nobody has the faintest idea so
i'm going to assume it stands for mango
at the moment the only real rival to
mango theory
is something called loop quantum gravity
the basic
idea is that the universe is not
continuous like we think it is
but rather a series of absurdly small
chunks
linked together where these links get
twisted or braided
particles form like string theory there
is no experimental proof this theory
might actually work
and probably more concerning nobody's
found a way to incorporate gravity
so as a theory of everything it might be
a bit useless
other theories include quantum einstein
gravity
quantum gravity internal relativity and
e8 an 8-dimensional mathematical pattern
with 248 points that can be used to map
the fundamental forces
and particles of known physics to
understand what those guys have been
eating
watch my recent video about magic
mushrooms
none of these approaches has had enough
research and support
to be tested as a true theory of
everything
so it seems we're still pretty far off
but what does that matter would anything
in your life
change if you suddenly understood the
ultimate theory
probably not still it would be kind of
nice to be able to say we've
defeated the final boss and completed
physics you know just to show off thanks
for watching
you can now buy my new book stick a flag
in it on amazon
or get the audio book on audible you'll
find a link to both in the description
below
thank you